dévastent certains milieux
naturels et causent des dommages
en agriculture. Les cerfs de
Virginie sont en surabondance
dans le sud du Québec,
et plusieurs se demandent
aujourd'hui comment gérer leur
population. On tient à vous
en aviser, certaines images
en début de reportage
pourraient choquer.
- (narrateur): Les routes du
Québec traversent bien souvent
villages, zones agricoles et
forêts; et ne sont pas toujours
sûres, surtout en début de
soirée, où les rencontres
sont parfois imprévisibles.
Ce genre d'accident impliquant
un cerf de Virginie a doublé
depuis 8 ans au Québec, passant
d'environ 4000 en 2012 à plus
de 8000 en 2020. Ces impacts
avec des cervidés font près
de 400 blessés chaque année.
Plusieurs de ces collisions
surviennent dans les régions
du sud du Québec, où les cerfs
abondent un peu partout.
Ici, on les surprend sur
une terre agricole. Là-bas,
on les retrouve dans les cours
arrière de résidences durant
l'hiver, où ils se régalent
dans les haies de cèdres.
♪ ♪ ♪
Le cerf de Virginie,
un cervidé de la famille des
chevreuils, a une durée de vie
d'environ une dizaine d'années.
- La plupart des animaux qu'on a
domestiqués dans l'histoire de
l'humanité, ce sont des ongulés.
Donc c'est des animaux qui,
en général, sont tolérants
à la présence humaine, donc
les moutons, les chèvres,
les vaches... On est tout dans
la même famille des ongulés,
des ruminants, comme un cerf
de Virginie.
- Le ministère de la Faune
évalue aujourd'hui cette
population à 250 000 têtes
au Québec; près de 325 000,
si on inclut ceux de l'île
d'Anticosti. C'est le double
de l'inventaire réalisé
il y a 30 ans.
Même si leur nombre varie
beaucoup selon les secteurs,
plus de la moitié
des populations de cerfs
sont concentrées dans
le sud du Québec.
- Donc, quand on est
davantage dans des régions
Centre-du-Québec, Estrie,
Montérégie, on est vraiment
dans des populations abondantes.
- À certains endroits, on peut
compter jusqu'à 30 cerfs au km2,
alors qu'une densité viable
pour l'habitat est estimée
à environ 3 à 5 cerfs au km2.
- Quand on arrive au-delà
du 5 cerfs au km2, où est-ce
qu'on peut même arriver dans ces
régions-là à plus de 10 cerfs
au km2, là, on commence à avoir
des dommages au niveau de
l'habitat, des problèmes de
cohabitation. Donc là, oui,
on peut parler vraiment de
populations très abondantes.
- Cette vidéo amateur montre une
quarantaine de cerfs de Virginie
traversant la route du Port
à Nicolet. Un rituel qu'ils
répètent matins et soirs
durant l'hiver.
♪ ♪ ♪
Tous ces cerfs ont élu domicile
sur les terres de Jean Leblanc.
Ce matin-là, il rencontrait
son représentant de l'Union
des producteurs agricoles.
- Si on regarde à ma droite,
là, jusqu'au plus loin, il y a
un troupeau d'environ 100
chevreuils qui passent l'hiver
ici. Puis, dans les champs qui
a autour d'ici, c'est sûr que
s'il reste des résidus de maïs,
ils creusent puis ils mangent
les feuilles, tout ça.
- Lui-même agriculteur,
Daniel Habel représente près
de 5000 producteurs agricoles
et acériculteurs du
Centre-du-Québec.
- C'est les producteurs qui nous
interpellent pour des dommages
aux champs, pertes de récoltes,
piétinement. Ça cause des
dommages au niveau de la forêt,
au niveau des installations
acéricoles, puis au niveau
des champs aussi, là.
Le cerf de Virginie est nourri
sur le bras des agriculteurs
à l'heure actuelle.
- Ces types de dommages,
on les retrouve un peu partout
dans le sud du Québec,
comme ici dans cette sapinière
de Barnston-Ouest, en Estrie,
où les cerfs ont dévoré
la base des conifères.
Ailleurs dans la région,
il n'est plus rare d'apercevoir
des attroupements de plusieurs
dizaines de cervidés dans les
champs agricoles. Mais comment
expliquer cette surabondance
de cerfs de Virginie au Québec
alors qu'il n'y a pas
si longtemps, l'espèce
était en déclin?
- Dans les années 70, il y a eu
une décision qui a été prise
puisque les populations
étaient très, très faibles et
diminuaient. Donc, il y a eu ce
qu'on appelle «la loi du mâle».
Donc en 1974, le gouvernement du
Québec a décidé d'axer la chasse
sportive sur le segment mâle
adulte, en épargnant justement
les cerfs sans bois, qui sont
les femelles adultes puis les
jeunes de l'année, les faons.
À partir de la fin des années
90, début des années 2000, de
plus en plus, les populations
ont augmenté.
- Un autre facteur contribue à
cette augmentation : les hivers
ne sont plus ce qu'ils étaient
au sud du fleuve Saint-Laurent.
La neige et le froid ont
longtemps été des régulateurs
naturels des populations de
cerfs de Virginie. Un hiver
plus rude pouvait faucher
le tiers d'une population.
Mais les temps ont changé.
- Au cours des dernières
années en Estrie, Montérégie et
Centre-du-Québec, il n'y a plus
d'hiver rigoureux pour le cerf.
Donc les taux de mortalité
sont beaucoup plus faibles,
presque absents au niveau
de ces populations-là.
- Les cerfs sont donc devenus
très nombreux. Ce qui les
force à explorer de nouveaux
garde-mangers, des sources
d'approvisionnement qui les
rapprochent de plus en plus
des humains. Et ce nouvel
environnement les protège
de leurs prédateurs naturels
comme le loup, le coyote
ou le lynx roux.
- La présence humaine fait en
sorte que les prédateurs sont
moins présents, moins efficaces,
ce qui vient favoriser le
cerf de Virginie directement.
- Un autre prédateur est aussi
moins présent : le chasseur.
Depuis 2007, le Québec a perdu
près de 38 000 adeptes de la
chasse au cerf de Virginie.
En 2020, on en comptait 136 413.
- Donc on n'a pas le choix de
ramener la relève de chasseurs
à cette pratique-là au niveau
du loisir, du sport.
Par la suite, on a haussé la
limite de prises par chasseur,
qui était globalement d'un
cerf par chasseur au Québec.
Maintenant, il est de
deux cerfs par chasseur.
- En 2020, les chasseurs
québécois ont abattu
plus de 48 000 cerfs.
De ce nombre, on retrouve près
de 5000 faons, 29 500 mâles
et seulement 13 600 femelles.
- Le groupe qui est responsable
de l'augmentation de la
population, c'est évidemment
les femelles parce que c'est
elles qui produisent les jeunes.
- Lorsque les ressources sont
abondantes, les jeunes femelles,
à un an et demi, vont se
reproduire, et très rapidement,
à 2 ans et demi, vont avoir
des jumeaux, des triplés.
- Si on veut réduire la
population, dans les études
qu'on a faites, c'est vraiment
qu'il faut augmenter la
mortalité des femelles adultes.
Donc ça devrait permettre de
réduire, si on veut, les taux
d'accroissement des populations
puis, éventuellement,
de stabiliser.
- Donc en 2020, on a haussé le
nombre de permis de cerfs sans
bois. Et même, dans d'autres
périodes de chasse, il est
possible de récolter ce
segment-là pour justement
mieux contrôler les populations.
- Mais pour chasser plus de
femelles, il faut accéder à leur
territoire. Or, le problème,
c'est que 86 % des zones de
chasse au Québec sont situées
sur des terres privées.
- Le propriétaire d'un terrain
peut pas interdire la chasse,
mais il peut interdire l'accès
au territoire. Ou il peut donner
l'accès au territoire, mais
à un nombre tellement faible
de personnes que le contrôle
potentiel des cerfs de Virginie
est plutôt faible.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La surabondance des cerfs
n'affecte pas uniquement les
zones rurales. Un grand nombre
d'entre eux se déplacent vers
des secteurs plus urbanisés
de la Rive-Sud. Grâce à des
corridors naturels comme des
golfs, des boisés ou des terres
agricoles, les cerfs peuvent
avoir accès aux parcs de
Longueuil et de Saint-Bruno,
puis à ceux des îles de
Boucherville et l'est de
Montréal.
- On commence à avoir des
problèmes de surpopulation de
cerfs dans les milieux urbains,
périurbains. Donc ça, c'est
des problèmes de cohabitation.
On doit passer à l'action avec
les intervenants du milieu.
Les municipalités ont aussi
des responsabilités à assumer.
- Pour diminuer les populations
de cerfs sur leur territoire,
certaines villes, comme
Sherbrooke, ont eu recours
à une chasse contrôlée
en n'autorisant que des
armes à moindre portée,
comme l'arc et l'arbalète.
- Mais cette chasse-là doit être
modulée pour assurer, bien sûr,
la sécurité des citoyens, tout
ça. Donc un parc peut être fermé
pendant quelques heures pour
récolter quelques bêtes et
tout ça. Si cette solution-là
n'est pas possible, bien,
il faut regarder les autres
options possibles.
- Quelles sont ces autres
options pour les cerfs
en surnombre?
Peut-on les transporter
et les relocaliser ailleurs?
- Les relâcher en nature
ailleurs, c'est une fausse
solution. Ça s'est fait
ailleurs, ça a été mesuré. Une
grande proportion des animaux
meurt à l'intérieur de l'année
qui suit. Donc éthiquement,
c'est questionnable.
- Sinon, peut-on stériliser les
femelles? Et si c'est possible,
comment le faire?
- Il y a une façon, c'est par...
chirurgical, le classique,
pour stériliser. Puis il y a
un moyen comme de vacciner pour
les rendre ni plus ni moins
infertiles. Là, c'est deux
injections.
- La difficulté, c'est qu'on
n'est pas encore tout à fait
au point avec les contraceptifs.
Il faut quand même probablement
les capturer puis l'injecter,
donc ça demande l'immobilisation
chimique des animaux;
donc ça impose un stress.
Puis cette méthode-là, elle est
pas permanente nécessairement.
- Pour mieux contrôler la taille
des populations de cerfs dans
les parcs urbains, plusieurs
scientifiques recommandent
la capture avec euthanasie.
- Évidemment, ce serait mieux
parce que là, c'est fait
par des biologistes ou des
professionnels qui vont dans
les parcs. On minimise le plus
possible la souffrance. Puis,
il y a pas trop de risques non
plus pour les gens qui vivent
autour. Donc ça, c'est la
solution qui serait envisagée.
-.Oui aux chevreuils!
- Mais pour plusieurs résidents,
l'abattage des cerfs
n'est pas une solution.
- Malgré qu'on récolte entre
40 000 et 50 000 cerfs de
Virginie par la chasse sportive
au Québec, quand on arrive en
milieu urbain, périurbain,
on est dans un autre contexte.
Donc souvent, le cerf de
Virginie est très émotif
au niveau des citoyens
et citoyennes.
- Dans ces milieux-là, bien, les
gens connaissent pratiquement
les cerfs de Virginie par leur
nom, ça fait que je comprends
que les actions létales peuvent
être difficiles à accepter.
- Les enfants adorent les
mammifères. C'est des espèces
qui ont de grands yeux, qui sont
beaux, qui sont intéressants
à regarder. Je comprends
tout à fait les gens, pourquoi
ils veulent les protéger.
Par contre, ça augmente,
ça continue d'augmenter
puis là, les animaux deviennent
en mauvaise condition. À un
certain moment, l'écosystème
peut complètement balancer, puis
on perd la forêt qui est là.
- Donc il faut prendre le temps
de bien comprendre le contexte,
d'éduquer un petit peu :
qu'est-ce qu'est vraiment le
cerf de Virginie, sa dynamique
de population rapide, et les
dommages que ça peut causer
aux écosystèmes et à l'habitat.
- Le cerf cache la forêt. Le
cerf est une espèce magnifique,
charismatique, qu'on aime tous.
Et le dommage à la forêt,
d'ailleurs, on le voit presque
pas, il est très discret.
Mais il est présent, il est
chronique; comme un feu qui
brûlerait tout le temps.
Ça fait une vingtaine d'années
que c'est brouté de façon
chronique; eh bien, là,
c'est les espèces envahissantes
qui en profitent.
- Le ministère veut bien sûr
assurer la pérennité des
cheptels à l'ensemble du
territoire québécois, et même
au niveau des municipalités,
mais à un moment donné,
il y a un certain contrôle
qu'il faut assumer pour
bien gérer les populations.
Sans ça, on arrive vraiment
à des problèmes sérieux.
- Des problèmes sérieux de santé
publique comme les risques
de transmission de la maladie
de Lyme par les tiques; et les
cerfs en transportent beaucoup.
- C'est que le chevreuil, lui,
permet aux tiques d'être en
santé puis d'en avoir en masse.
Comme dans le parc de Longueuil,
où je suis présentement, étant
donné qu'on a une surpopulation
de chevreuils, on a également
une surpopulation de tiques.
- Au Québec, l'Estrie et la
Montérégie sont les secteurs
les plus touchés par la maladie
de Lyme. Incidemment, ces deux
régions sont aussi confrontées
à une forte population
de cerfs de Virginie.
- Ça a été démontré
en Nouvelle-Angleterre,
dans certains milieux où une
diminution des populations
de cerfs a été associée à
une diminution des populations
de tiques et une diminution
des cas de maladie de Lyme
dans la population humaine.
- Il faut pas oublier
que la situation actuelle,
on y a contribué.
On est rentré dans l'écosystème
d'une façon peut-être plus
ou moins adéquate, puis là,
on est en train d'en vivre
les conséquences. La question,
c'est : qu'est-ce que la
communauté veut faire avec ça?
- Et pendant que les Villes,
les propriétaires terriens et le
Ministère essaient de s'entendre
sur les actions à prendre,
la croissance des populations
de cerfs se poursuit
dans le sud du Québec.
- Les effets du cerf de Virginie
deviennent plus importants
et plus rapides que les effets
des changements climatiques.
Ils ont la capacité de convertir
des écosystèmes encore plus
rapidement que le changement
climatique le fait lui-même.